All I have to say as I hope there is
such a thing as clean coal.
And the reason I say that,
uh,
and of course that means that we can
burn coal and completely capture the co
two and then cause sequestered.
And it's certainly not an easy thing to
do.
But what I keep reminding people as a
kol is the world's most abundant energy
resources.
Now you can argue whether it's as
abundant as solar or wind,
but certainly in terms of conventional
resources and what people forget is that
coal employees,
literally tens of thousands of people
around the world,
not only in our own country,
but in places like India and China.
It is cheap.
And so it's very difficult for emerging
market countries that are trying to
electrify to,
uh,
the grow their economies.
Uh,
economically it's very difficult for
them to simply say,
well,
we're going to stop using coal because
of concerns about climate change because
not only will they throw thousands of
people out of work,
but they will not then,
and probably in the near term,
have a readily available alternative,
uh,
to replace the coal generated
electricity.
That's leading to these explosive,
uh,
levels of economic growth.
So I hope that we put a lot of research
and development.
Uh,
uh,
there are essentially three major ways
that we think about right now to,
uh,
to potentially have clean call.
One involves taking the coo to help me
for combustion and to capturing it after
combustion.
But I would like to see us cooperate
with the other big coal users and
Indonesia and China,
India,
and maybe jointly embark on some
research and development projects using
these three technologies.
And,
uh,
not see it as a commercial gain of one
country is going to learn how to do it,
not other,
but,
but Santa,
the rubric of the global good that we
all do it together.
And then your share the benefits
accordingly.